各位朋友大家好
非常高兴今天能够有这个机会
来为大家分享
数据安全领域的法律法规体系解读
那么这是我的一个简单的自我介绍
在保证文本内容的准确的情况之下
使用了我年轻时候的照片
但是大家相信虽然胖了一点
但是确实是本人
这是我多年以前留学的时候的一张照片
当时可能还比较掀心
那么我们今天来为大家分享的主要内容
其实是三个大的板块
第一个部分
我们将会为大家来简单的介绍一下
数据安全领域法律法规的基本框架是什么样子的
第二我们将会以其中最为重要的数据
三反的前几条的内容来构建
为大家看得好
很像比较数据立法的这么一个立法目的
调整范围和调整对象到底是什么
然后最后我们将会重点的
以数据安全法的一些核心制度
和一些代表性的案例为线索
来为大家介绍一下数据安全法
所规定的数据安全领域中的主要的安全制度
有哪一些
那么我们首先看两个简单的案例
第一个是徐玉安
徐玉是山东的一位高中生
在她毕业以后考上了大学
学家都正在高兴的时候却遭遇了毕业新诈骗
被骗走了学费
导致徐玉同学伤心欲绝
最终不幸的心脏咒停一事
这个事情也告诉我们
其实在某些情况之下
数据安全或者说个人信息的安全
不仅可能会关系到我们的财产
这种诈骗不仅谋财可能还会害命
那么我们看第二个案例
第二个案例是美国最大的燃油管道运输商
运营商
他由于遭遇了什么呢
勒索软件的攻击
他的部分重要数据被加密了
必须要提供赎金才被解密
由于这么一个攻击事件
导致全美有接近一半的
这么一个输油管道网络出现了几个小时
甚至是十几个小时的暂停
对整个国家安全
社会经济的安全造成了一个重大的影响
所以通过这两个案子
我们会发现
其实数据安全不仅仅是关系到
个人的财产
企业的财产
实际上是对个人的生命安全
甚至是对于整个国家的
这么一个国家的主权安全
都会有重大的风险
那么我们国家
其实在数据的发展过程中间
也非常早就关注到了这么一个问题
通过法律立法的方式
进行的一些安全到底的完善
那么这个安全到底的完善
我把大概的框架
称之为叫N加3加2
所谓的N
实际上是只一般性的法律
但是中间对数据安全
进行的一些规定
比如说民法典
比如说刑法典
我们很早刑法典
就对网络安全
数据安全各的契机
保护进行了一些规定
那么还比如说
像反不正常竞争法等等
它也对数据做了一些相关的规定
那么这一些N
是一些一般性的法律
后面的3加2
这是专门性的法律
其中的3
就是最为重要的
我们称之为叫数据三法
里面主要就是网络安全法
数据安全法和个人信息保护法
他们是整个数据安全的基本框架
那么除此之外
还有两部国务院
所颁布的行政法规
来规定数据安全中间的
一些具体的领域
其中就是一个
是关键信息激动设施的安全
另外一个这是网络数据的安全
这是我们所说的N加3加2
成为一个大的框架
共同构建的数据安全中间
领域中的法律法规的
这么一个体系
那么在这个体系中间
最为重要的
当然是我们念的数据三法
那么数据三法
我们想要为大家
把其位的前几条
来做一个横向对比
实际上这个前几条
在很多这个
如果是咱们法学的一些同仁
在学习法律功能中间的时候
有时候就能忽略
而认为前几条比较务需
它没有规定具体的规范性的内容
但其实不是这样子的
我们看数据安全的前几条
其实可以很明确的从中间
发现很多这个有意识的地方
也解除我们过去的一些误解
比如说数据安全的立法目的
到底是什么
这个问题好像是很简单
数据安全立法目的
当然会为世卫的数据安全
真的是这样子的吗
如果仅仅是为数据安全
那么绝对化的数据安全是否存在
我们经常举个例子
就是我有一个调号码
这个调号码是一个数据
这个调号码也是一个个人信息
对不对
但是我把这个调号码
把它锁进保险规定面
不告诉任何人
那还有意义吗
实际上我们发现
这个没有意义了
我们为什么要规定数据立法
数据安全的防御规范
是因为我们处于数据经济时代
而数据经济时代的重点是什么
是要利用数据
所以绝对化的安全保障
如果阻碍个利用的时候
实际上是有问题的
那我们看数据三法
到底怎么规定的
我们先看网安法
第一条这么规定的
叫保障网络安全
维护主权国家安全
社会利益
保护公民法正西亚组织合法权益
促进社会经济
经济社会信息化健康发展
我们看到有保障有维护
有保护还有促进
那我们看数据安全法
这里面就更加明确了
叫规范数据处理活动
保障数据安全
促进开发利用
数据的开发利用
保护个人组织的合法权益
维护国家主权安全的发展利益
中间规定的几个动作
第一个是规范行为
第二个是保障安全和权益
第三个就是促进开发利用
实际上这三个目的是必须的
那我们再看个人信息保护法
它继续原用的这样的结构
叫做保护个人信息权益
规范个人信息处理活动
促进个人信息的合理利用
所以我们看到从数据三法的第一条
我们就会发现
实际上规范保护促进三者是一体的
我们在理解整个数据
安全的这么一个法律制度中间的时候
我们不能够绝对化的
僵化的去理解安全这个问题
安全保障不是唯一的目标
它是要跟规范行为和促进合理利用相结合的
那么这也会对我们后续的一些制度的理解
产生一些相关的影响
那我们第二个问题
那数据三法的适用范围是什么
它保护的对象又是什么呢
首先我们要看数据三法的调整范围
这和一般的法律就出现了一些微妙区别
也同时会对我们后面的一些制度
我们就会提到一些制度上的一些问题了
我们过去的传统的法律
我们无非就是数据或者数人
数据就是在中国大地上发生的事情
我们就管
数人就是对于中国人所涉及的问题
但是我们看数据三法
网安法还相对来说是比较明确的
使用了什么数据管理
在中国的这么一些网络我们来管
但是我们看随着时代的法律
我们发现不太够了
然后在数据安全法
数据安全法的立法是比网安法稍微晚一点点的
我们看到我们不仅规定境内的
而且对境外的进行了一个什么
叫做保护性的一个保管理
叫做是你如果在境外开展数据数据活动
但是损害了我们国家或者我们公民组织的权益的
我们同样可以管理
然后我们再进一步的看个人信息保护法
个人信息保护法
一方面来说还是以境内为主
但是同时它对境外相比数据安全法
又做了进一步的扩展
什么就是你除了说可能会危害到
我们的公民法人组织国家的力量之外
你如果是在境外对吧
处理我们国家自然能的个人信息活动
然后存在一些相关的情况的时候
也是需要使用个人信息保护法的
所以我们看到数据三法它体现出什么
就是代表了数据的流动性
我们过去很多行为
你在国内就在国内
在国外就国外
它其实连续信没有那么的强
除了一些走私这么活动
它可能有很强的境内境外的连续信
但是数据由于它天然的流动性
网络由于它天然的流动性
实际上你完全只靠一个属地原则
只靠这个国境来进行区分
是不够的
所以我们看到在网安和数据安全
和个人信息保护法中间
它实际上都一定的扩展了属地原则
所以这是整个数据安全的法律规范
一个很重的原则
它其实具有一定的跨区讯息
有一定的国际性
我们后续看距离制度的时候发现这个问题
实际上国家与国家之间
关于数据管辖的一个冲突
是数据安全制度领域中间的
有一个某种程度上是一定它的一个特色
也会为我们数据安全法的适用
其实产生一些问题
我们后续再来解释
那么什么是数据呢
实际上我们看到
网安、数据、个人信息保护法
产生都做一些相关的界定
那么这里我们要注意一个有意思的特点
网络安全法
当时最早的时候界定的数据
讲的就是电子数据
这个没问题
因为它是以网络为主导的
但是到了数据安全法中间
以及后续的个人信息保护法中间
还来讲的时候
就有一个很重要的特点
它不极限于电子数据
是以电子和其他方式存储的
对信息的记录都属于数据
那么这里我们就要注意一个特点
都属于数据
那么紫字档案受不受数据安全法的管理
而我们今天有个签到本
我们讲说同学们来签到
有的签到本上面有对个人信息的签到
但这个本质
受不受个保护法的管理都受的
实际上我们这里尤其要注意的就是
实际上现在我们关注到
实践中大量的数据安全的泄漏
或者个人信息保护的泄漏
是怎么泄漏出来的呢
比如说疫情期间的一些流调数据
比如说有血管员拿了紫字档案
拍了照上传
发到了相亲相爱的家人
很多数据是这么流传出去的
所以紫字的数据的管理
不能够去忽视
这是我们对于数据
我们对于法律所要保护数据的界定
或者数安法的界定的时候
我们的一个重要的一个并解的内容
那么同时数安法对于数据的保护
还提了一个非常重的一个概念
叫做分级分类
分级分类就是把数据分为一般数据
重要数据和国家核心数据
它实际上是按照什么来分的呢
是有两种逻辑
第一个逻辑是它的重要程度
第二个逻辑是它如果一旦出问题
它的危害程度
重要程度和可能的危害风险程度
把它进行了分级分类
分成的简单的分是分为这三类
当然还有更多细节的分法
那么为什么要分级分类
这就是提到了我们一开始所讲的
绝对性的安全
实际上在数据经济和数据社会时代是不够的
我们还是要分类来看
一般的数据
我们可以稍微让它的安全制度
稍微宽松一点点来让它更好的利用
但是越是重要
或者是风险越大的数据
我们越要更高标准的
更严格的管理
所以通过分级分类
实际上是进行一个分风险的分级管控
来给不同风险
不同重要性不同价值的数据
来匹配不同的管理制度
所以这也是我们为什么一开始就要结合第一条
我们来看
实际上这就和整个数据立法的立法目的
结合在一起
那么数据的分级分类
是这么一个基本的一个大的这么一个思路
我们再看下面一个数据中间比较特殊的
特别领域就是个人信息
个人信息应该说在整个数据中间
是相对来说比较特殊的
因为它一方面有风险
另外一方面离我们老百姓特别近
所以对于大家的获得感特别强
一旦被侵害了
我们个人感知是非常强的
那么个人信息
由这里面要注意一个重要的特点
就是它是要与以识别或可识别的
自然人相关的信息
完全另明化的信息
它是不算个人信息的
要完全另明化的信息
比如说中国有14亿人
这个绝对的统计信息
实际上你是无法指定到
具体的个人的
我们所有人的报寒在里面
或者你说在广州这么个地方
有多少人具有什么样的一种特征
由于这是一个完全无法还原到具体个人的
因为你也不知道我说的是谁 对不对
但这时候就是一个另明化的信息
另明化的信息
统计性的信息是不受各办法的约束的
但是并不是所有的我们看到
去标识化的信息
就是另明化的信息
我们这提了两个概念
一个要去标识化
一个叫另明化
另明化是完全无法还原了
你不知道是谁
去标识化是你去了个标识
但是有可能你根据这个标识
还能确定到是谁
那这个时候
那这个信息
它就有可能仍然受到各办法的约束
这叫做去标识化
那么在这个过程中间
我们举个例子
比如说我们今天看到
有时候我们叫猛猛猛
或者叫李猛猛王猛猛
这些信息是去标识化的
还是另明化的呢
我们是要放到特定情况下来看的
比如说曾经我这有个案例
就是某一个小区打出了一个横幅
说猛猛小区挤挤动的
什么李猛
由于诈骗 被骗多少多少元
我们注意啊
这个横幅上的李猛
在结合他的动的楼洞信息
实际上是可以去还原到他的
因此这个信息
我们某种程度上来说
只认为它是个去标识化的信息
而不是一个完全另明化的信息
所以在整个各办法的处理作用中间
我们对于这个另明化和这个去标识化
是个比较复杂的问题
我们要注意去进行一定的区分
那么与这个个人信息相对应的进一步
是敏感个人信息
那就是由于涉及到生物识别
宗教信仰 特定身份
金融账户 行踪轨迹等等原因
以及不满未成
不满实事之后
所以的未成年人
由于这些原因
它比一般的个人信息更为重要
更为敏感的
然后我们把它定为敏感个人信息
那么敏感个人信息应该说
这些年来说也会对我们
我们日常生活中也会经常遇到
其中一个很重要的其实就是人脸识别
人脸识别我们这两年其实看到了
很多越来越广的使用
但是从此也产生了一些争议
比如说我们这里可以看到
人脸识别的第一案
把郭斌 郭斌上也是个学者
郭斌老师
郭斌老师可能当时也是看到
这个国内的人脸识别的这么一个情况
他作为一个法学的一个老师
对学内比较敏感
我们看这个案子是什么呢
这个案例上是我们老师被称之为
叫人脸识别第一案
是讲郭老师他买了一个
也是动物园的双人脸卡
这个动物园的脸卡以前是靠按手印
按指纹
后来改成了人脸识别
郭老师说我不愿意把我的人脸给
那我要说推卡
动物园不同意
后来起诉了
最后法院认为
你如果要使用人脸识别
这涉及到敏感个人信息
你要他本人同意
人家不同意你不能强制
那怎么办
第一退钱
第二删除郭老师
当时存储过的所有的智慧信息
我们注意这个案子是2019年
然后是2019年
当时我们的各网法其实是没有通过的
但是法院已经从学里拿到层面
对人脸的这么一个敏感个人信息
实际上是进行了一定的关注
那么与此对应的是
我们看到是最高法院
也出台了关于人脸识别技术
处理的一个司法解释
我们也要注意这个司法解释很有意思
这个司法解释
实际上是在各网法社校前一天出来了
所以某种程度上来讲
它不是对各网法的解释
而是对于人脸的这么一个特殊的敏感信息
在原有的法律的框架之下
就可以得出这么一个解释了
但是各网法只是一个更加明确的规定
那么在这里面
其实用一个很重要的一个特点是什么呢
其实就是物业的信息
这个物业的这些信息
应该是要提供一个替代性的选项的
比如说我们以前进出物业都必须人脸识别
而现在我们看到的是
进出物业你可以人脸识别
如果说某个人同意
但如果他不同意怎么办
你要给他提供一个替代性的选项
比如说你可以说半个卡
对不对
或者这种指纹
所以这也是为什么
我们给很多APP的开发者
我们进行一些沟通的时候
很多APP开发者
后面的问题
马老师我这个业务必须要人脸识别
比如说银行那些APP
我不人脸识别
我不安全
那我必须要人脸识别
那你现在不能强迫我人脸识别
我一定要给一个替代性的选项的怎么办
我说你尊重消费者的选择权
你愿意人脸识别
我给你便利
你可以在网上办理
如果你始终不愿意人脸识别
没问题
我给你一个替代选项
你去线下办理
对吧
你不要把线下的办理的渠道给断掉了
如果有个消费者自己就一定
不愿意把人脸给你
他宁可自己麻烦
每天去跑营业厅
那你要给他提供一个替代的选项
如果你觉得每个营业厅
安排一个人脸的办理
线下的业务太麻烦
那你一个城市总有一个营业厅的办理
对不对
你给一个选择
这实际上是各宝法
一个很重要的特点
就是你要给消费者
或者说给自然人一个选择的空间
那么我们看到下面
26条实际上是各宝法
一个进一步的规定
各宝法
我们注意到人脸识别
在这个现实中间
实际上是大量存在的
各宝法商
最后把它进一步的限定
是这种身份采集的
个人信息的采集设备
只能用于维护公共安全说必须
你只能用于安全
你才能够做这个人脸识别
除非老百姓自然能同意
否则你在公共场所也好
在其他地方也好
你布置这个摄像头
公共场所布置的是个摄像头
只能用于安全目的
有大家可能会问
除了安全目的
还有什么目的
音效目的
我们看到新闻报道过
很多受容户
安装的人脸识别设备
来为了解
所以我们看到一些新闻报道
甚至有些人买房的时候
带了一个头盔
这个也非常有意思
但是同时这也就告知了
我们一个问题
人脸识别的精准音效很好用
但是个人信息保护法
现在实际上是对它
进行了一个强有力的限定
因为它属于敏感
敏感的个人信息
所以需要得到一个
更高层级的保护
所以做了一个特别的限制
好 那么我们刚刚介绍了
整个各宝法
或者说我们说数据三法
基本的框架的基本的限制
基本的设置之后
我们下面我们来看一下
它们具体的制度讲了什么
当然今天因为时间的原因
我们很难将
三部法律的内容
全部讲一讲
那么我们主要今天讲一讲
数据安全法中间的
一些重要制度
和一些重要的内容
那么证明的重要制度
除了我们刚刚
刚刚介绍过的
分级分类之外
我们来看看
还有哪些具体的制度
我们看这里列了
三条制度
监测预警制度
应急处置制度
安全审查制度
使用这三个制度
都是一些很基础的
我们其实看这里
可以观察到
数据安全法的一个颗粒度
数据安全法的颗粒度
其实是比较大的
规定的还是宏观上的
一些安全制度
具体怎么落实呢
其实还是有很多
部门规章和具体的文件
去操作
那么在这三个制度中间
我们可以重点讲一下
安全审查制度
这个制度是非常有特色的
我们看到人们讲述的
叫做是
国家建立数据安全审查制度
对影响或者可能影响
国家安全的数据安全制度活动
进行国家安全审查
注意了
第二款
依法做出的安全审查决定
为最终决定
什么意思呢
如果说我们是
学法律师朋友
这次就很敏感了
意味着
数据安全的国家审查
是不可以负义
也不可以输送的
它是一个最终决定
原因是因为
它关系到了国家安全
因此在某种程度上来讲
它会有一定的
国家安全的政治属性
这时候我们更强化的是
一省中省
叫做一个决定中省
不再去安排其他的
这么一个数据渠道了
这实际上是很类似于
一些跟海关
或者是一些体现出
比较强的国家
主权属性的一些制度中
所出现出来的
那么关于这个
数据安全审查之路
实际上在我们的整个
最近的经验中间
已经有多次发生了
比如说
一个受到境外企业的
是美光
而涉及到境内企业的
大家也比较了解的
就是某出行企业
这个出行企业
它这个交通
当时还有很多交通数据
出行数据
然后在2021年
由于某一些事件
而且就是说
它还在境外去上市
等等原因
引发了一个
比较集中的爆发
那么当时国家
为了防范国家数据安全风险
维护国家安全
保障公共利益
实际上是一句
网络安全法
相关的法律法规
对它进行了
一个数据安全审查
那么在数据安全审查的最后
是认为它违反了
网络安全法
数据安全法和个人心理保护法
行政筹法法的
相关的法律法规
给予这个企业
予以80.26亿元的
一个高额的处罚
同时对它的
相关的领导人员
进行了个人的一个罚款
所以我们看到了
整个数据安全的
这个领域中间的
这么一个审查
它实际上是很有可能
会产生一个
非常强大的一个处罚后果的
这实际上也是
数据安全领域中间
一个比较一色的特点
那么我们看
其他国家也是如此
欧洲 基于GDPR
实际上是
做出了几个
巨大的巨额罚单
都是数亿欧元
甚至是十几亿欧元
这么一个处罚的可能
那么这种某种程度上来讲
它一个很重要的原因
是因为这些处罚
往往都是根据
这个企业的全球营收来算
根据它的全球营收
或者根据它的总营收来算
而这些数值的一些巨头
或者是重大的平台企业
它实际上在全球
有广泛的业务
所以它的总营收的比例
总营收的这个份额是很高的
所以当你这个法律规定
对它可以进一百分之二
百分之三 百分之四的处罚的时候
它实际上的这个费用
就非常的高
所以我们看到
在数据安全领域总监
我们经常会看到
一些天价罚单的存在
这实际上某种程度上来讲
一方面是展现了
对于数据安全的重视
另外一方面
其实反映的是
数字经济的活力
因为数字经济有这么大的盘子
有这么大的体量
才会出现
这么重大的一个处罚
所以数据安全
对于这么重大的数字经济
它同样也体现出了
一个很重要的一个作用
那么第二个
我们再看相关的这么一个制度
那就是出口管制制度
出口管制制度
实际上就是意味着
某些数据你是不能出去的
我们也看到
我们国家在不断的出台
一些关于技术出口的
一些限制的名单
那么除了技术之外
数据本身
也是有一些进行管制的要求的
这里与之相关
还有对等反制制度
其实我们刚刚提到了
数据是涉及到跨境的
大量的数据
实际上涉及到境内境外的问题
而数据这个法律领域
天然的存在
跟国际斗争有一定的关系
待会我们会讲的
有些其他的制度
会更加明确
但在这里面
我们其实已经出现端理了
实际上在这个数据的
法律的治理过程中间
它有很多问题
实际上是带有国际性的
甚至会成为国际斗争的一部分
我们具体来看
扣扣管制的这么一个制度
这个制度具体实现
它是很丰富的
但是我们看到
它暴露出的一些问题
有时候是通过一些
很特殊的各地暴露出来的
比如说我们看一下
这个案例
叫做数据出境限制的第一案
它对应的
除了我们刚刚所提到的
这个出境管制制度之外
还有一些相应的
出境限制的一些制度
这个案子
我们看到它的具体信息
其实来自于交电访谈
它非常的重要
进行了全面的这么一个报告
那么这个案子
大概是什么一个情况呢
其实讲的就是
有上海的一个科技公司
有一个员工
他被拉进了一个微信群
群里面有人说
是一个境外企业
要委托中国公司
开展对一些数据的调研
但这里的数据调研
由于他们
疫情期间不能够来划
所以希望委托境内公司来进行
主要是收集
中国铁路的一些信号数据
包括物联网封窝和
GSMR的评普的一些数据
当时这个企业
为了赚钱
很快就答应了这个项目
但是其实他们当时
也出现了一些敏感
对这个案子的合法性
对这个项目的合法性
心中是有一些
有一些疑虑的
所以当时他们还请教了
公司的法务
而公司的法务
是明确告诉他有风险的
你们还要注意
但是我们看到这个公司
虽然说知道有风险
但是觉得收益还是很关的
怎么办
于是他们做了个办法
就是向境外企业问
你们有没有一些
合法性的一些文件
要求对方来提供
但是境外企业
跟他们打太极
说这个东西没关系
怎么怎么样
不停地吹出他们尽快的
来完成这项工作
然后他们要求对方
实际上是完成这个工作
是通过一些普通设备
就可以的
比如说是一些简单的设备
这个设备不是什么间谍设备
就是很普通的设备
所以这个公司当时就有点放松了
觉得都是普通设备
没有关系对吧
然后利润很丰厚
于是他就开始
在做这个工作了
这个公司
即使是认为有合法性的疑虑
但是他同时还是开始
进行的操作
那么在这个过程中间
他们约定了两个阶段的合作
第一个阶段是固定采集
第二个阶段是要去到
移动设备的各个地方
进行移动采集
然后这个采集过程中间
最开始是要求把数据
纯入硬盘
然后寄到海外
但是由于担心海外
在邮寄过程中间
出现一些问题
最后这个东西
不断的进一调整
最后甚至是出现了一些
远程端口
就是国内的公司在这里采集
境外的公司直接
通过端口
从国内来调取相关的数据
甚至可以登录
这些远程的端口
实际上到这一步的时候
我们就会发现
一步一步问题
是不是越来越大了
一开始是你采集
这些数据
你还可以自己整理
整理之后
如果有敏感性的
你可以把它提出一下
到后来
实际上这个境内公司
完全的成为了境外公司
采集的这么一个白手套
所有的数据从境内
直接有流向的境外
没有经过审查
也没有合规的要求
而境内公司
以上不能控制
这些数据到底怎么办
所以在这种情况之下
其实境内公司对这个风险
其实是有越来越多的明确了
但是由于它的收益太高了
所以他们还是挺而走
现在做
这些数据一个月
采集到了数据
就达到了将近500期
最后呢
经过坚定发现
这些数据实际上是一些敏感数据
这些数据很有可能对国家安全
对我们的生产经营安全
造成严重的影响
而属于数据安全法里面
所规定的
静止出口的相关的一些数据
然后呢
最后呢
这个案子在处理过程中间
我们注意一下
这个案子比较有意思
在于是
这个案子最后
它是上到了刑事责任
当然我们知道
刑法是非常特殊的一个法律
就是罪刑法定
所有的罪名
必须有法
由刑法来规定
最后呢
这个案子在刑法处理中间的时候
把它认定为
叫为境外刺探非法提供情报罪
这里的数据
同时构成了刑法上面
所说的情报
之后我们发现
这个数据出境
如果说
你没办法做好它的合规
你没有办法按照合规的
比如说合规要求来进行完善
它就是很有可能
触犯到刑法的
在这个案子中间
我们也看到了这个企业
其实一开始
他请教了法务
但是法务给了意见
他最终没有踩辣
他也没有做相关的合规的准备
就是为了利益行而走险
最终使得自己触犯到刑法
也同时给国家带来的巨大的损失
那么我们再看另外一个案子
这个案子或者叫案例吧
这个势力
这个势力相对来说
就是一个比较好的势力
那就是什么
特斯拉
特斯拉在中国建立的数据中心
实现所有的数据跟电话存储
我中国的数据
我在中国存储
我在中国的数据在中国训练
减少数据不必要的数据夸挤
大大增加了我们数据的安全的程度
这反过来也让中国的企业和中国的政府
对于中国的老百姓
对于特斯拉更加信任
对吧
你的数据都在我们的境内
那我们就可以更加安心地来进行使用
这是一个
我们说刚刚讲的这个负面案例
那么这里讲的是一个
相对来说
好
那么我们前面讲的是
数据夸挤
数据出入境的这么一个
宏大的一个名题
那么在具体的工作中间
或者是我们在具体的
这个数据的管理中间
数据安全法
还规定了很多具体的
数据安全保护义务
实际上就说
你任何企业或者个人
你处理数据
你要完成相应的
这么一个数据安全保护的义务
建设相应的数据安全保护义务
建设相应的数据安全的保护制度
如果你没有建设
你没有去
没有去完成这么一些义务的话
你可能就会有相关的法律责任
那么我们这里可以看一下这个案例
第一个案例
是一个价培学校的数据安全违规案
广州警方发现
一个公司所开发的价培的平台
培训的平台存出了大量的
学员的姓名
身份证号 手机号 个人信息
但是这个公司没有按照
数据安全法的要求
去建立数据安全管理制度和操作规程
对于日常经营活动
采集到的大量个人信息
没有去标实话
也没有加密措施
系统甚至可以存在
Wave授权就可以访问的漏洞
这样一些严重的数据安全隐患
这意味着你这个平台上
存了这么多个人信息
你又不保管
就很容易泄露出去
产生数据和个人信息的安全风险
所以广州警方对于这个公司
进行了一个行政处罚
从这个处罚的额度上来看
我们更多的看
额度其实不高
更多的其实是警戒 告戒
我们其实现在越来越多的企业
我们其实是掌握了大量的个人信息的
很多时候我们的企业
又喜欢去采集
觉得采集的信息越多
我是不是以后更有价值
但你采集了之后
你能不能保护好
权力越大 责任越大
你掌握了越多的数据
你管理越多的数据
你拿了越多的数据
你就一定要管好它 保护好它
这是很重要的一点
数据领域中间
权力和义务和责任是相对应的
你拥有越多的数据
拥有越大的权力的同时
你就承担了
越大的数据安全保护意义
数据安全
数据它实际上是一题的
我们这样讨论一个问题
叫数据全属的问题
这个问题我们今天时间有限
我们不展开谈
但我们可以简单的讲一点
数据全属它实际上是全贼一体的东西
你拿到一个数据
你拥有一个数据
你首先拥有的是安全 义务和责任
之后才是利用数据开发利用
所可能享受到的一些乱和benefit
但是一开始的算是责任和义务
这其实也是对我们所有的数据处理者
悄想的一个紧重
那么第二个案子
我们看到的实际上是小区
刚刚那是企业
对吧
第二个我们看看小区
小区的物业公司中间
发现存了大量的人脸识别数据
车辆安全管理的数据
明文存储了相关的个人信息
其实这样的明文存储我们不少见
很多企业拿个XLR文档就存了
对吧
那这个XLR文档你加密了吗
没有的
同时大量的系统存在
登录账号弱口令
账号没有设置全线设置
这个我们也很常见
对不对
你这个密码
一二三四五六
八八八八八八
这些弱口令是大量存在的
那也意味着任何人
只要打断这个电脑
都可以登录上去
所以说我们注意到了
整个相关的这么一个安全制度
其实在过去我们
应该说我们是有很多疏忽的
我们习以为常了
但是我们疏忽了
以前是没有出现安全事故
但是一旦出现的损失就会惨重
所以我们看到在这里面
泳洲市的公安部门
对这个公司进行的警告
这个没法款
先警告你
因为毕竟还没出事嘛
那么警告希望你改正
实际上我们看到这样的事情
在我们应该说生活中
或者说我们工作中是经常出现的
那么我们也希望每个听众
我们在作为这个研究者
或者作为法律试用者
试用的同时自己先做好
回去看一看我们的这个公司
或者说我们自己的这个系统
我们的机构
我们有没有掌握相关的一些数据
尤其是一些敏感的重要的数据
那这些数据
我们有没有建议相应的保护机制
这种保护机制
不仅仅是技术上的
其实很重要的也是制度上的
比如说你说像登录账号弱口令
是因为技术不支持
复杂的口令吗
当然不是
其实更多的还是制度上面
没有更好的去落实
那么我们下一个讲的一个很重要的一个制度
其实是数据采集
或者是要数据收集的一个方式的制度
数据安全法
实际上对这个数据收集
是规定了几个比较特殊的
不叫特殊吧
几个一般性的要求
就是合法 正当
同时如果法律法规
对它的目的和范围有限制的
还要在特定的目的和范围内进行收集
这里就要求我们的数据采集
你不能够非法 也不能不正当
不正当是对应的什么
对应的就是所谓的不正当的数据采集
这里面就涉及到不正当竞争的问题
待会我们有案例
我们回来详细聊一聊
实际上这个很有意思
不正当到底什么是正当
把隐身出了对数据
现在我们的保护方式
边界的一个规范
我们现在很多数据
我们先看到
我们现在法律上面
是没有规定数据全熟的
应该说我们的法律上面
暂时还没有明确规定
一个物权性的数据权
我们司法裁判中
如果遇到数据案件
我们怎么处理
只要是根据反不正当竞争法来处理
那这里反不正当竞争法就意味着
你如果对数据采集
你是正当的
那就合了
如果你不正当
那你就不能去拿到这个数据
那对于数据的持有者
或者说我是拥有数据的人来说
我就如果对方的目的是正当的
那我就把数据要给他
如果对方的数据
对方拿的是不正当的
我就可以通过反法
来经历我自己的互惩和
来保护我的数据不流失
来保护我的这么一个数据
所谓的一个权数
所以这个正当这两个字
看起来很简单
其实里面是引发了
很多丰富的类似的
那么同时对比来看
数完法规定的
对于数据收集方式
是比较简单的
但是个人信息保护法
将会有更加详细的规定
由于数据
个人信息相对而更特殊
它怎么采集
它的方式
各宝法就做了
非常详细的列举
这里我们不去展开了
好 那我们来看
我们刚刚讲到了不正当
如果是正当的
要求是正当
什么叫不正当
我们看第一个案子
这个案子叫做
数据交易满寿人商业
秘密侵权第一案
这个案子首先是讲的
某一个摩托车
汽车的制造商
原告
某与摩托车
和被告
某雅摩托车
两个都是
摩托车的生产出口企业
然后这个某雅出口公司
和这个第三方公司
签了一个合同
购买摩托车出口
前十位的企业数据
然后这个第三方数据公司
就提供了
包含某与公司在内的
各种详细的出口报单的情况
包括出口目的地
规格型号 排量
单价 总价 申报数量
等等等等
具体的一些项目
然后某雅公司
在接收了
这么一个数据之后
同时还像其他的人
也披露和使用了
这些某与公司的数据
某与公司也不开心
这些数据
我的报关数据
你怎么可以获得呢
于是某与公司
就提出了法院
就原告
认为商业秘密倾全了
那么我们看法院
当时怎么裁判的
法院在裁判的时候
认为这个数据上面
是承载了很多的
个人信息
商业秘密和公共利益的
所以数据处理
数据使用者在使用
接收 控制 运用数据的时候
要有合理生生的义务
原告被告是竞争主体
有类似的外贸竞争模式
那么这个被告某雅公司
在看到你这个数据里面
有竞争企业的具体品牌
具体型号 具体数量
具体单价
这一些特殊组合的时候
你是有伤
你自己对这些数据
你也觉得很敏感
对不对
你应该是要知道
这些数据
是侵害到别人的商业秘密的
所以你知道
这个侵害商业秘密
你还继续使用
你就应该去承担
一定的赔偿者的
于是法院最终
是赔偿
这个被告败述了
被告要给原告
赔一件钱
其实赔的也不多
但是这里面就体现出了什么
体现出了法院
对于这个中间
这个数据
到底够不够的商业秘密
它有一个
它的判断的一个观点和机制
形成了这么一个案例
这个案例当然是存在一定争议的
实际上关于数据
到底什么是正当
什么是不正当
他们的判断
其实是比较复杂的
我们看到反不正当竞争法
在最近修改过的中间
其实专门增加了一条内容
是关于数据
关于这个不正当
采取数据的一个限定
而这个反不正当竞争法
在征求意见搞混的中间
这一条其实更丰富
理由大概将近
又七项的具体的列举
如果大家有兴趣
可以去看
这里面其实也可以
作为我们的理解
什么情况之下
数据采集是正当
什么时候不是正当的
一个扩展性的参考
那么与之相对应的
反不正当竞争法
领域都是数据采集的
或者说更著名的
影响更广的一个案子
就是微博书漫漫案
在微博书漫漫案里面
其实法院是对于
反法的一个利用
是产生的生源的影响
这里面这个案子
大概什么情况呢
就是微博
我们都知道
是一个社交媒体
卖卖是一个职场
社交的软件
或者说是一个
职场的社交软件
最早期的时候
微博和卖卖是合作的
微博可以
卖卖可以直接用
微博账号就登录
但是后来合作结束了
微博就不让卖卖
用他的账号登录了
那卖卖想个办法
你微博不让
我找用户
比如说我一个用户
我想登录卖卖
然后这时候卖卖
就会问你
那你愿不愿意
把你的微博的信息
迁移到我的卖卖上
用户同意了
于是卖卖就去微博上
爬这个用户的信息
爬取
爬了之后
把它复制到这个卖卖上去
这个过程中间
我们注意
卖卖是拿到了用户同意的
但是微博就说了
用户同意
我微博没同意
你这时候来爬我的数据
你构成了一个
不真当真正
于是两者
双方
来进行了这么一个诉讼
在这个过程中间
其实法院
就提出了一个
很重要的一个观点
法院认为
这个过程中间
实际上
卖卖去拿到微博的这个数据
微博对于这个数据的形成
是有贡献的
你这个东西
做去不是用户
我直接产生的
我用户跟用户
当然密切相关
但是企业在里面
微博在里面
也是有贡献的
于是法院
认为
如果你要正当的
去把这个数据拿到
其实你有一个
故状的过程
叫三重授权
这个三重授权
是什么意思
就是首先
用户要同意微博
把数据给出来
然后呢
微博也要同意
把数据给出来
最后
用户要再次同意
把这个数据落下去
给卖卖
等于说
用户要同意数据拿出来
微博要同意数据拿出来
用户还要同意
这个数据落下去
用户同意两次
企业同意一次
完成三重授权
才能构成一个
正当的数据过去
所以这个案子
能影响非常的深远
实际上也是得告诉我们
实际上我们在分析
一个数据的
你获取数据
是否正当的时候
它其实考虑的因素
还是挺丰富的
它既有个人的因素
也有企业的因素
好 那么我们再了解
完了这个数据的一个
获取的这么一个
正当性的问题之后
下面
我们要来看
一个非常有意识的
一个领域
我们刚刚提到
数据安全领域中的跨进行
国际斗争的重要性
我们在这两条中间
体现了零零精致
这两条实际上是一个
我们看有点像个镜像条款
它的意思是什么呢
第一个 三十五条
是说国家安全
国家公安机关
国家安全机关
依法调取数据的
应当按照国家有关规定
经过严格审批
依法进行有关的
组织个人
应该配合
这里面有两个层面的意思
第一个意思是
国家对于老百姓
对于企业要数据
不是说没有任何限制的
它是有明确的限定的
你要有法律依据
经过法定程序
由法定主体来进行才可以
数据是很有价值的
不是说国家随便就可以把他拿走的
你要拿走 一定要有法律依据
而且是要经过程序的
所以我们对老百姓的数据
对于企业的数据
是有很好的保护的
但是第二个来了
如果说
公安机关 国家安全机关
依法来找你要数据
你肯定是要配合的
对不对
这个35条实际上
就给了一个授权
那么与35条相对应
如果境外的机关
我们前面讲的是
我们国家的机关
找老百姓要数据
找企业要数据 要配合
那如果是境外的机关呢
如果是境外的司法机关
或者司法机关
找我们境内的主体要数据的
要经过我们国家的
主管机关批准才可以
你不能自己私自给出去
好了
我们这里想想看
这个从我们国家的角度来讲
当然似乎没有问题
但是我们想一想
那对于企业来讲
比如说像TikTok
TikTok比较特殊
它本身在境外
比如说我们境内有些企业
在美国上市的
在美国上市的时候
美国的证券机构
或者司法机构
司法机构是有可能
向他们调数据的
调会计地账的
那这时候
它就必须要通过
我们国家的机构的同意
你才能把数据给出去
其实有些企业觉得
好像这样的是不是
这家企业的负担
让我们企业夹得中间不好做
但这个问题真不能怪我们
为什么不能怪我们
这个事情
某种程度上来讲
我们的数捐损法也是学的
学了谁呢
我们看美国的Cloud法案
这个案子是什么回事呢
2016年微软起诉了美国政府
为什么起诉
是发现美国政府
经常在调查中
使用一个叫
秘密指令的东西
用这个秘密指令
去调取微软云服务中的用户信息
而且还要求微软
不能告诉用户
你们掉了
好了 那微软就很麻烦了
我的数据
我把我用户的数据
给了美国政府
美国政府也不能让我告诉用户
那以后
如果真的出了问题了
那岂不就微软被国
微软为了防止被国
就起诉美国政府
这个案子
打来打去
打来打去打了很久
最后出乎意料的解决了
那就是美国
直接立了一个Cloud法
这个法案立完之后
最高法院认为
本案已经没有实际意义了
因为法案
已经给了明确的法案
那我们看这个Cloud法案是什么
Cloud的法案
云法案
但其他的内容
是这个说写
就是澄清境外数据的
合法使用的法案
这个法案的内容
其实就很简单
就是美国的执法机关
可以调数据
调它境内的数据
比如说
调相关的
微软的服务器上的数据
如果是境外的机关
像美国调数据的
要通过美国的统一
要通过美国的
事法协助等等
相关的程序和要求
其实和我们的数据
完全是类似的
所以你就会发现
其实确实
由于不同的国家
在数据的
这么一个管辖上
管辖范围的交跌
它确实都跨区域管辖了
而不是局限于
这么一个境内原则
确实会使企业
有可能会加在
两个国家中间危难
这实际上是
现在跨境企业
一个非常大的难题
但是我们必须要认知到
这也就是
国际现实
但是可喜的也是
其他各国之间
也在经过不同的企业商
在这个问题上面
达成一些企业
尽量的去给企业的
尤其是跨国企业
跨国的互联网数据企业
他们提供一些便利
这中间有一些企业
已经完成了
有一些还在讨论当中
那么关于未来企业
应该至少认知到
这样的法律风险
是巨大存在的
这是个客观现实
所以我们看到
有很多企业
确实不容易出海的时候
那么我们要理解到
这么一个显示
同时在法律上
做好合规工作
还尽可能的去完成合规
保护好自己
否则又会出现法律风险
那么除此之外
我们看到数据安全法
还规定了很多具体的
一些制度
这里面可能比较有特点的
或有代表性的事实条
那就是关于
电子政务系统的
一些管理的要求
我们知道
其实我们国家的
电子政务
输入政府的建设
其实是比较先进的
在全世界范围内当
现在我个人认为
还是很有代表性的
那么作为一个政府
它管理的这些数据
其实也具有高敏感的
一些特点
所以数据安全法
对于国家机关的
这么一个数据安全
或者说是电子政务的数据
有一些特殊的要求
那么这里
我们可以看个案例
这案例也挺有意思的
就是23年的时候
我一个科技公司
为一个县级市
开发运为系统的时候
没有经过
特克建设单位同意
把建设单位采集的
敏感业务数据
上传到自己
租用的公有云服务器上
造成的数据泄漏
这肯定是一个
严重违法的行动
最终被进行了新政处罚
那么这里实际上
也是我们这样讲的
一个问题
就是政务数据
不要离开政务域
然后我们经常
现在看到
通过公司合作的方式
其实有大量的
这么一个企业
政企合作
有很多企业是进入到了
电子政务的开发领域
这当然很重要
因为企业有技术
有实力
有企业来进行
电子政务的
相关的一些开发和运营
能够成本更低
但政务人中间
一定要注意
电子政务的数据的安全
这个数据不要离开政务域
而且企业
你只是作为一个服务商
进入到这个领域
你并不是说
获得了这些数据的控制权
其实这些数据
当我们先看到
制度上其实有很多
更安全的做法
比如说
双重DBE的一些双重确认
任何数据释放
需要不同的机构
共同的确认
又或者说是
我们看到一些要求
就是要求这个企业
对于这个数据
不能离开预管理
所有的数据
要在本预中间
企业可能获得
只是一个仿真数据
或者是一个逻辑目录
这个物理数据是不迁移的
通过这样的方式
在技术和制度上面
对于政务数据
提供一些更多的保护
因为政务数据
和一般的数据相比
它的敏感性 重要性
其实相对来说是更高的
好 那么这里
就是我们关于整个数据安全法
的重要的一些法律法规体系的
一个简单的介绍
那么由于时间有限
其实关于网络安全法
和个人信息保护法
还有很多丰富的内容
我们这一次没有办法去展开
包括像我们记得
刚刚有一点点到为止的
就是想数据的权属
数据的产权
数据的反不挣让竞争
等等
其实跟整个数据的法律法规
都是密切关联的
那么这一些
我们以后有机会
再为大家请您分享
那么也非常感谢大家
能够听到这里
谢谢大家
也祝愿大家能够在
未来数据治理的领域中间
获得更多的成就
谢谢